bonjour nicolas vidal merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors le
coc u19 1 marqué une rupture au sein de
notre pays et nous essayons de
comprendre à ses causes et ses
conséquences
comment dans un premier temps vous
analysez ssr allocutions des vannelles
macron lundi soir je dis moi je les
trouvais martial et violente temps ne
s'attendait pas à une telle rétorsion
social mais régnante français beaucoup
étaient abasourdis
dès la fin de l'allocution ils sont
allés se couchait qu une drôle
d'impression
comme si nous venions de basculer comme
si nous venions de changer d'époque sans
le savoir un claquement de doigts un
soir de juillet comme si le jour d'après
n'aurait plus la même saveur que celui
qui venait de s'écouler plus que le
choix n'est proposée plus aucune
alternative n'est promise
plus aucun doute et accepté ce lundi 12
juillet pour des millions de gens dans
ce pays
on leur a enlevé ce cas tellement
fondamentale à chaque citoyen mais c'est
quoi baisser le libre arbitre le droit à
choisir et à décider pour soi même
l'égalité la liberté de vivre
sereinement dans une nation qui a été le
phare des droits de l'homme faut-il le
rappeler est comme prise en récup
française décide seul de ne plus laisser
le choix à ses concitoyens people
changement radical est extrêmement
dangereux pour la suite et ce matin nous
allons essayer de comprendre dans quel
monde nous venons de basculer ici en
france et justement nicolas vidal vous
parlez du monde d'après quoi pourrait
ressembler justement ce monde d'après le
12 juillet mais vous le savez à la
république a toujours est-il coercitives
et violente par le passé pour rassembler
les français autour d'un projet
collectif et les différentes républiques
il faut le savoir ont toujours émergé
après des troubles et des violences mais
il y avait quand même un soubassement
avec l'idée d'une nation plus égalitaire
et de monde un peu plus meilleur mais
depuis ce 12 juillet la coercition
officielle d'état viennent de remplacer
la république anh officialisant les
citoyens de seconde zone
la masse des parias et la confrérie des
intouchables alors nous sommes
aujourd'hui bien au-delà de la question
médicale de la crise sanitaire et de
cette nécessité qui fait loi
nous parlons aujourd'hui d'un changement
brutal du contrat social qui nous unit
les uns aux autres qui emmanuel macron
vient de déchirer sans le consentement
des français pour le remplacer par la
division la segmentation et la
discrimination d'état
heureusement que emmanuel macron s'est
toujours considéré publiquement comme un
libéral imaginez s'il s'était dit
autoritaire et l'or quand c'est que les
forces de l'ordre ne seront pas
concernés ni par l'obligation dé finale
ni par la réforme des retraites ça
laisse rêveur sur les intentions du
président et il faut dire que lorsque le
chef de l'état s'est présenté face aux
français il a tranché il a brisé et
imposer des mesures avant même de passer
devant la représentation nationale
une nouvelle fois emmanuel macron fait
peu cas de la souveraineté du peuple
français a décidé pour lui-même mais
pour un féru de start up nation
ils devraient savoir que même le pdg
d'un grand groupe passe devant son
conseil d'administration avant de lancer
des changements cruciaux
mais aujourd'hui nous vivons ce
désenchantement du monde dont parlait
max weber avec la mise sous tutelle de
la population sous camisole sanitaires
il n'y a absolument plus rien qui compte
depuis mars 2001 à park waber par le
comique on a banni la capacité à se
poser des questions avec les accusations
de complotiste et rappelez vous il ya
quelques mois que ceux qui annonçaient
la situation actuelle était prêté de
quoi et bien deux groupes autistes et
avec du recul
cela a été le meilleur gestes barrière à
l'intelligence et la citoyenneté les sa
chambre ils ont pris le pouvoir
médiatique et ils ont mis en place les
bases du monde d'après contre l'avis
d'une grande majorité de majorité ou
d'une grosse minorité renvoyer dans les
bourrasques déconfinement successifs
alors ne pensez plus fraternité ne
pensez plus liberté ne pensez surtout
plus égalité mais concentrez-vous sur la
santé car la santé est devenue la valeur
cardinale de la soumission à tous les
décisions politiques et à toutes les
phrases que médical depuis un an et demi
car la démocratie et l'émancipation pour
certains sont des propagateurs puissant
du corps et dix neuf et ça ce n'est pas
envisageable
alors ceux qui ont tenté de rester dans
le monde d'avant et de ne pas se faire
arracher leurs droits fondamentaux sont
devenus de dangereux dit responsable
mais pourquoi
car après trente ans de consumérisme
forcené en a consigné l'horizon des
français à leur petit bien-être
personnel
la notion que l'équipe de nation s'est
arrêté au cours de l'école élémentaire
mais l'hédonisme et égoïste
il a asséché notre destin national il a
déconstruit notre avenir en commun
aujourd'hui on ne parle plus de français
mais de vacciner et de vacciner
nous sommes au bout du processus de
désintégration la vis d'elle vous
parliez tout à l'heure de division est
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un réel un
risque de fragmentation des français
autour de ce pass sanitaires
obligatoires
ah oui il ya clairement un risque dans
ces temps que cet objectif restera
l'ultime conditions de survie
individuelle
ce sera le cas tant que la santé sera
érigée finalement au dessus de la
liberté individuelle et collective
dynamique folin accélérée par l'état
lui-même depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
aujourd'hui il n'est pas question de
crise sanitaire il est question notre
destin commun en tant que français épris
de liberté
épris d'égalité épris de fraternité qui
emmanuel macron vient de faire voler en
éclats pour des raisons bassement
électorales comme certains le pensent
plutôt accepter la discrimination la
suppression des libertés et la vindicte
qui va peser sur des millions de
français car c'est aujourd'hui la
question que nous devons tous
collectivement nous poser sur la
servitude que nous impose la santé avec
son lot d'autoritarisme et de coercition
la france n'est pas un agrégat du numéro
de sécu et le qr code
la france est forgé comme une nation de
citoyens et de démocrates
ce sont nos valeurs et notre histoire
qui ont bâti au fil des siècles notre
démocratie qui est plus que jamais en
grand danger
même si l'état n'aura pas les moyens son
autoritarisme imposer par la force des
pas une marque de responsabilité ni
digne de prix dans la république et
surtout pas à la hauteur de la france
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal avoir été
avec nous ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes éditorialistes merci beaucoup